foreign
[Music]
my name is Hannah padorski and today I
want to talk to you about how I adapted
current Tools in environmental science
through R by advocating for automation
and to start I want to tell you a little
bit about my colleague let's call him
John
I work with a lot of Johns
John might be a biologist a chemist
maybe a geologist he's been in his field
for quite some time and he has a lot of
very important technical knowledge
within his field but little to no
knowledge on modern day programming
languages
in addition to this John keeps getting
handed data sets that are much larger
and more complex complex than what his
current tools can handle
and on top of this just like everybody
else he's got too many tasks and not
enough time
so this is the type of scenario where I
would advocate for automation my goal is
to streamline the processing of data so
my team has more time to apply their
technical knowledge to the problem at
hand
but John might be a little bit hesitant
and I understand that
um because as a programmer I would much
rather spend five days automating
something than just five minutes to do a
simple task
and because of that not only today I'm
going to am I going to talk to you about
how I used R to automate workflows but
also how I reduce the activation energy
it took to get my team on board
so in chemistry activation energy is the
energy needed to get from one side of a
chemical reaction to another
and you can reduce the activation energy
by applying a catalyst
so when I want to move my team from
their current workflow to an automated
workflow I can reduce the activation
energy by rephrasing how I pitch
automation starting small and being a
little bit creative
so let's start with the pitch and most
importantly that word automation it can
be a little vague and feel dependent but
what I mean when I say automation is the
streamlining of a workflow by reducing
unnecessary human interactions
so my team has more time to spend on
greater value tasks
and most times when I pitch automation I
don't even use the word automation I say
let's streamline this workflow
um so let's talk about the difference
between workflow and that I
traditionally see which I'm going to
call for the purposes of this talk
reactionary workflow and automated
workflow
so let's say we have four work products
a b c and d a might be our database B
might be our tables full of summary
stats C is our figures and D is our the
text that goes into our final report
say we have to update our database maybe
we know that we need to update our
database like we need to go out and
collect more data or maybe we don't know
and maybe someone found an error in unit
conversions at the last minute
well with this change now we have to
manually update all of the workflow
Downstream
where in comparison an automated
workflow
if you have to make that one change to
your database you can use functions or
scripts to automate the processing of
that one edit and apply it to all of
your work products Downstream and this
is a I know a very simple definition of
what automation is and streaming Landing
of workflow but I like to lay it out
like this because it makes the pros or
benefits of using automation very
obvious
so number one reproducibility because of
those scripts or those recipes that are
being completed by a computer you know
you're going to get the same thing every
time and this is important not just when
you can predict you need to update
something like we're going to do annual
sampling events but also when you can't
predict you're going to need to have
some update something like when you
catch an error in a simple mathematic
equation
also it can be extremely simple and
though it pains me to say this this type
of workflow can be accomplished in Excel
workbooks just maybe not at the current
scale we need
um it saves time because you're reducing
that human interaction and also reducing
the amount of Errors which saves my team
time in quality control and quality
assurance
so I found it helpful to start small
with tasks that can be automated in the
same amount of time as the original
tasks and so for me and the projects I
work on this is most likely going to be
moving tables of summary statistics and
figures out of Excel and into r
but most importantly I like to try and
meet my team members where they are and
that's going to be by creating work
products they're familiar with and at
least in my case that's going to most
likely be Microsoft Office Products
so I'm going to talk about two packages
I love for doing this the first one
being open xlxs it's a package designed
to edit read and create Excel files in r
so traditionally when I go to save a
data frame in R I'm going to write it as
a CSV however more recently I've tried
to force myself to save more of these
data frames especially the ones I know
that are going to be of interest to my
team to Excel files
I mean that's because I want to help
them with this transition between the
reactionary workflow and the automated
workflow because when they're working on
so many projects at the same time and
they're used to all their files being
Dynamic and constantly changing
and also all written in Excel and you
throw one CSV in there
more than ones have they opened that CSV
in Excel added a few tabs highlight a
few cells saved it and closed out and
since those edits are not supported in
CSV they just lost all that work so by
me making the simple change of Simply
saving data frames as dot XLS files I'm
helping to reduce the activation energy
and get my team moving forward towards
automation also I love open xlsx because
it allows me to make formatted Excel
tables in R such as the one you see here
and it's great for when I have to put
together hundreds of tables that I'll go
into a back of the report a back of a
report which I'm sure eventually one day
someone might look at maybe
ah
also I love to use officer officer
allows you to manipulate
um Word documents and PowerPoint
documents in our I use it mostly for
exporting ggplots into PowerPoint and so
here's just example code doing just that
but what I want to do is I want to point
out the rvg package and the function DML
so running your ggplot object through
this in our case our GDP object is plot
through this function before you export
that figure to PowerPoint allows you to
actually edit that figure in PowerPoint
so here's an example of a plot I created
and exported to PowerPoint using the
code from the previous slide it's the
concentration of chloride over time
and since I used the DML function I can
move around my annotations change them I
can change the let I can change the axis
titles and the legend and this is great
for if my team wants to just have a
little bit more control of the final
product
um or if they just don't like where The
annotation is currently at or if they
want to make last minute nomenclature
adjustments this makes it great so we
can still interact in addition with
officer you can use PowerPoint templates
to create placeholders and then you can
add things like figure captions figure
numbers notes logos so I can automate
the process of creating these figures
and Export them from R into PowerPoint
so they're ready for a report
so now that I've got my team a little
bit on board I've started with these
smaller tasks now I can take on bigger
tasks that might require a little bit
more
um of initial investment and delayed
gratification
so I'm going to talk just about that a
specific example where my team decided
to automate software developed by a
regulatory agency
so that software is pro UCL Pro UCL was
developed by the U.S Environmental
Protection Agency or EPA and it
specializes in performing statistical
analysis on left sensor data in
environmental Sciences we have a lot of
less censored data we whenever we're
measuring the concentration of some
compound in water or soil or air
depending on our methods and our
equipment we have something called a
detection limit and below that detection
limit we don't know where that
concentration will sit it can be
anywhere between zero and our detection
limit so there's a lot of uncertainty
around that
So Pro UCL takes that uncertainty into
account when doing the statistics when
doing Simple statistics like means and
standard deviations as well as more
complex statistics like distributions
and upper confidence limits So Pro UCL
is definitely it's solving a problem for
us but it has some less than great
design features one of which is it will
crash if you put too much data into it
and by too much I mean about 10 000
records which for the type of projects
we're working on which require us to
analyze hundreds of compounds at in a
variety of environmental media we were
having to run Pro UCL multiple times and
because of that we decided we wanted to
try and automate it and we decided to
try and automate it by using
a um a mini a mouse macro so in our case
it's called Minnie Mouse macro
and basically automate the clicking of
the software itself
so
we have we wrote a function in r that
allows us to subset that data into more
manageable chunks and then you run the
function and it creates an input file
for our Mouse macro and then it runs
that file so the mouse macro input is
just a simple text file I used some
command line code to open up the mouse
macro and load in the input file and
then it just
clicks through the software for you so
here it's using the text string we gave
it to input the location of the input
file it's clicking through all about the
drop downs we'll need
and then it's loading in the compounds
we want to look at
and finally it'll save that file to the
text string I gave it for the output
file
and then once it senses that there's
information in that file it'll close out
of pro UCL and if necessary run it again
so we'll Loop this over and over and
over again and that might have seen like
a very simple process why would you
automate it well that was a very small
data set and there's actually a lot of
computation time that has to go into it
when you're doing larger data sets so
for small projects running Pro UCL
through the automation like this can
take 15 to 30 minutes but for bigger
projects we're talking just automating
like this six to eight hours
um so it's definitely saving us time
that way but writing the code to
automate the clicking of my mouse
through the software was actually the
easy part the hard part was deciphering
the output file
so here's what Pro UCL gives you as an
output file it's a formatted Excel sheet
this is just a small subsection of the
statistics it gives you and only one
compound so once again for our sites
we're looking at hundreds of compounds
and we might even have to group our data
spatially so we have additional
we'll need additional information
and so before we automated what we did
was just have someone go through and
copy and paste the values we were really
interested in
um and that took quite some time so
instead we automated it and now we
create tables both unformatted and
formatted in Excel that my team can use
for their analysis and their final
report
so overall my team thinks this went
great it does exactly what we wanted to
do uh when we first decided we wanted to
automate Pro UCL we saw two pass we
could go down one using our Mouse macro
the other just recreating all the
statistical tests in R and that
definitely would have been possible but
at the time we just didn't have the
resources or the time to devote to such
a project in addition Pro in addition
Pro UCL is an industry standard almost
at this point it's been used for quite
some time and there's a lot of important
technical knowledge built into it so
using it is a benefit especially when we
have to deal with regulators
in addition Pro UCL is used on projects
such as risk assessments where we look
at how compounds in the environment can
affect different receptors like humans
and Wildlife
and sometimes we have to go back and
forth with regulatory agencies to Define
our conceptual model for a site which
means we might be adding in receptors we
might be adding in compounds we might be
changing how we spatially divide up our
data and that means we very rarely have
to just run Pro UCL once usually two or
three times
so automating it definitely saved time
it saved human error because less
copying and pasting but it's not perfect
um once I'm sure one day hopefully EPA
will update Pro UCL
and then my code will become obsolete
but at this point it's already paid for
itself it works it does what we need it
to do and we're happy for that in
addition there are other things I wanted
to do to help improve this function to
make it easier to use between
um for anybody but we just didn't have
the time so it does require some special
setup especially with the coordinates
for the clicking of the mouse you have
to make sure your screen resolution is
set appropriately
so final thoughts I gave you a bunch of
different hybrid approaches to
automation that helped me save time and
reduce human human error which
ultimately is what I believe the goal of
automation is and should be
um also I showed some easier examples
and some more advanced so I hope you
recognize that no matter what your skill
set you can benefit your team now
and maybe with just a little bit of
rephrasing of your pitch
starting small and being creative you
too can help you can reduce the
activation energy you needed to get your
team on board
um and reduce the road bumps along the
way
and with that if we have I can go ahead
and answer questions
also I wanted to let everybody know at
this link are my slides as well as
example code for the smaller examples so
the open xlss and the officer as well as
links to more information
[Applause]
[Music]